let's review everything we've done in
the last few videos and then take it a
few steps from there so let's say we
have a reality that right now and this
isn't the actual exchange rate but i'm
just using these numbers because they're
nice simple numbers the current exchange
rate is 10
10 1
per 1
u.s per one
u.s dollar and now we're in a reality
where the chinese government and the
chinese central bank wants to keep this
pegged so it wants to lock this
it wants to lock
this exchange rate right over here but
the reality is more is being sold to the
us more is being exported from china to
the us than the other way around and so
that leads to this weird dynamic that
we've studied in the last few videos so
this is china right here
this is china and then you have the
united states right over here
united states and let's say
at this exchange rate right over here
you have
let's say that you have goods coming
from china to the u.s actually let me do
it in that same magenta color so these
are chinese goods
so these are chinese goods
chinese
chinese goods
and then we are paying for those chinese
goods in dollars and those dollars are
being sent to china
and so we are paying
so let's say we pay
in this time period let's say it's a
year let's say that the 100
100 dollars
sent
to
sent to
china
for
for the goods and this is really just a
summary of what we saw in the last few
videos and let's say on the other side
of this equation some goods are sent
from the u.s to china
some are exported
so u.s
u.s goods
are exported to china and then we sell
them in china and then we get someone in
return that go back to the united states
and of course the reality the money
seldom is actually sitting on a ship
going across the pacific it's all in
these bank accounts they can be wired
back and forth the actual exchanges are
essentially happening in the in on the
internet not really you know in any
physical location but this is a good way
to visualize it so the us goods are
being sold in china and then the u.s
producer is going to get one and let's
say for their goods they get 500
they get 500
500 won so if all of these people were
to just convert and you actually don't
know what the equilibrium price would be
because the demand changes depending on
what the price is in each of the
countries
but if you really wanted to convert
these hundred dollars that the chinese
producer get into one at ten to one you
would need you would need so we're going
to assume that this peg is what what at
least the chinese government wants so
you would need
so this guy needs
let me put it here needs
needs one thousand
needs one thousand won
in order to convert all of his hundred
dollars at ten won per dollar
now this producer the us producer only
has
only has
let me do it in a different color only
has
only has and i should put the quotes
around needs not around the one now this
u.s producer only has 500
to convert
to
convert
into
dollars and we've seen this multiple
times but i really want to reinforce it
about how these currencies would
fluctuate
the demand for one is much higher than
the supply for one and we could do the
exact same argument with the dollar that
the demand for dollars is much lower
than the supply for dollars at this
exchange rate if we assumed a peg this
would only be 50
that we need to convert into while
there's a hundred dollars of actual
supply but let's just focus on the one
they need a thousand won if at this
exchange rate there's only a thousand
one that can be converted into dollars
and if we had a floating exchange rate
that would increase the demand for one
and then this number would go down or
another way to view it either that
number goes down or this number over
here goes up you could say it the one
would become more expensive which means
maybe it's 91 per dollar or eight won
per dollar or it could go the other way
for 10 wands instead of a dollar you'd
get a dollar ten or a dollar twenty or a
dollar thirty either way
now in order for this lock and for this
peg to occur we saw in the last video
that the chinese central bank needs to
intervene so the chinese central bank
the chinese central bank remember where
are the excess where are the excess
dollars they're over here let me make it
clear there's there's a hundred dollars
over here there's a hundred dollars over
here that need to be converted into one
we have 501 over here
we have the 501
501 that needs to be converted into
dollars
now the chinese government wants this
hundred dollars to be converted into a
thousand one
so what he does or what they do is they
say okay fifty dollars of this
fifty dollars
of
this hundred dollars can be essentially
traded for these 500 wands let me draw a
two-way arrow there fifty dollars
fifty dollars goes to the american
producer
and then the 500 won the 501 go to the
chinese producer four
four in exchange for that fifty dollars
obviously this isn't coordinated it's
not like matchmaking it's not like
someone said hey you give this money to
them but
essentially there will only be fifty
dollars to
convert into the one and then the other
fifty dollars the other fifty dollars
let me make it clear the other fifty
dollars
the other fifty dollars will go to the
chinese central bank
we'll go to the chinese central bank
so let me draw the central bank chinese
chinese central
central
bank and they will just print one and
give another 501
and they will just give another 501.
this is exactly what happened in the
last video i drew it a little bit
different all i'm showing is is to
make up for the the lack of supply of
one they needed a thousand one there was
only 500 want to convert in order to
make that up the chinese central
government prints the extra chinese
currency and buys dollars with it so
it's essentially it's essentially
sucking up it's sucking up the excess
dollars right this was excess dollars
right over here so that the dollar does
not weaken it is it is sucking
it is sucking up
extra
dollars so that the so that the supply
for dollars isn't
so high that it weakens or so that the
wand strengthens and so that's way the
chinese can maintain
the trade and balance they could
continue to export more goods than they
are
importing now what is the effect of this
though and we saw this in order to
maintain this currency peg while there
is this trade imbalance the chinese
central bank keeps printing juan and
they keep accumulating dollars
and if they ever stop
if they ever stop accumulating dollars
it's not like they can just hold the
dollars they have and the peg will hold
if they ever stop accumulating dollars
then the peg will break down they have
to do this every time period they have
to actively participate in the market
printing one and buying dollars they're
doing it every day to maintain the peg
not every day maybe sometimes when it
won't fluctuate on their own but if the
wand is getting expensive they actually
maintain a range they will buy dollars
so they're just buying they're just
accumulating more and more of these
dollars and now this is where it gets
interesting what does the chinese
central bank do with that cash
now like anybody cash is useless you're
not getting any interest on it it's just
it's really it's just paper
it it allows you to buy other things
that could give you some income or could
give you some value
so what the chinese central bank does it
doesn't hold actual dollar bills it goes
and tries to buy the safest u.s
denominated asset it can and another
thing not only does it care about safety
so it cares about
so it wants to go to a safe asset
it wants to go to a safe
dollar denominated asset
dollar denominated
which means that you would buy it in
dollars and if it produces interest the
interest would be in dollars safe dollar
denominated safe dollar denominated
asset and it's also doing this on a
massive massive scale in the hundreds of
billions of dollars and actually the
reserve is in the trillions of dollars
so it's on a massive scale so they can't
just go buy a random company's stock one
that won't be safe but also they would
just drive the price up to infinity if
they used they used this many dollars so
it has to be a very liquid asset
a very liquid asset one that has a very
deep market where the people trading in
that market it really is in the tens and
hundreds of billions of dollars and
there's really only one asset that meets
those requirements and that's u.s
treasuries
us
treasuries and this isn't the only thing
they will do but this is the great
majority so what the chinese central
bank does with all of these excess
dollars it essentially buys u.s
treasuries
so it
it gives the dollars away or not gives
away it buys
it sends the dollars
to the people who are holding the us
treasuries and then it gets u.s
treasuries in return
it gets u.s treasury's
u.s treasuries
now as a bit of review and i've done a
few videos on this what are us
treasuries u.s treasury bills and bonds
are loans to the
federal government
so these are that's maybe how you should
view it these are loans to the federal
government
loans to
federal
government
these bonds these treasury bonds or
these treasury bills that they're
getting these certificates
these certificates are essentially in
fact they are ious
ious from the usa
not to get cheesy with the acronyms
these are literally ious from the u.s
government and the u.s government will
pay interest they are essentially so
just to make it all clear of what's
going what's going on they're printing
money they're accumulating dollars
they're buying those they're using those
dollars to go out into either the open
market or even directly from the
treasury from the u.s treasury and they
are buying u.s treasuries which
essentially means they are lending this
money
this is they are lending this money to
the u.s government so they are
lending
to
the us
the u.s
government now leave you there in this
video and maybe you want to think about
a little bit before you even watch the
next one but in the next one we'll talk
a little bit about what that even means
what happens if you have this big holder
of u.s dollars this huge holder of us
dollars going out there and buying
treasuries and being willing to lend
money to the us government think about
it and in particular think about what
would happen to interest rates and what
those low interest rates impact would
have on the rest of the us economy and
on debt in general